it's just horrendous taliban hitting
people paris with no choice but to hold
the line
the road to safety is packed thousands
upon thousands
it's hard to put into words how
desperate this is but most of these
people will not get through
stay there stay there sergeant major gaz
mcmahon has a man's passport
on a container he calls him forward
a talib fighter lets him through
he passes the passports back
but he has to wait
the shipping containers have been put on
the road to keep the gates of the
british compound clear people funneled
through
the main shield soldiers called up to
reinforce the human wall beyond it's
constant
once through it's better but not much
again thousands penned in as the
identification process goes on
british and american troops are now
working together
trying to differentiate the countries
evacuees should go to
it's fair to say the soldiers have never
seen anything like this even the old
hands
sometimes you have it like absolutely
rammed with people pushing and chaos
outside other times it sort of calms
down what happens well sometimes we can
manage to calm the crowd down using the
local nationals to calm them down when
they see the processes working they're
calm when they start getting a bit hot
or whatever people start getting annoyed
we tend to find a lot of the people
causing the uh causing the disturbances
haven't got the correct documentation so
they certainly know the chance in their
homes
really this is all about time isn't it
you just got to crack on no i said
i'm going to be here forever could be
days
some heading to america have their
contact name held in the air
they've been here for hours but spencer
hasn't come
we've been in contact the crowd is just
crazy no one is helping and i don't know
if this keeps going no one will get help
we are requesting the government to fix
this are are you going to america or to
america i've been working with them for
five years
it's hot blisteringly hot british
soldiers spot a baby in danger they take
control with their family in tow they
make their way to the british compound
these are combat soldiers remember
they also care about what's happening to
the people here
well it's absolute pandemonium but funny
enough it's it's not chaos it's actually
just chaotic the british and american
soldiers are now working together and
that is a massive change and it's really
improved the system but they're still
trying to separate the people you look
down here
i mean you know there are thousands
they're working their way through it as
best they can
point remember though is if you come
this side
beyond the containers
it's absolute absolute chaos down there
and they're just cueing to try and get
inside
over the heads of the evacuees another
transporter plane takes off
that's what they're here for the flight
to safety
in the midst of all this sadness
sometimes just sometimes you see joy
breaking out
they are going in
waheed was a british army translator in
helmand
now he and his family are going to the
uk it's been agreed this is a very
a very happy day in my life
yeah have you got family in britain no
no no so you're the first yeah yeah i'm
going to go to burton that's my first
trip to britain and so you're waiting
just to get birthday yes it's scary
outside yes it was very scary it was
very hard to find outside like a zombie
like a zombie so zombieland yeah
what are you most excited about in
britain
to educate my family and my children to
uh to britain
and britain and become an engineer on
doctor in britain and serve for
afghanistan and forbid for british
people
would you know where you're going no i
don't know i'm sure
i'm not sure where we'll be but uh it
would be britain
[Music]
and somewhere yeah
time is running out for this evacuation
there is no doubt in that it's just a
matter of how long
not everyone who should go will
the majority in this streets outside
will not
very soon they're on their own
mr ramsey sky news